in Iran revolutionary sentiment flows
through its streets including those of
the capital Tehran hear vast crowds
descend on a Central Square to call for
the removal of the regime
in corvae residents silently marched
through the town the police watch from
the side while shops and businesses
throughout the country have shut their
doors the authorities accuse their
opponents of waging a war against God
the first protester from this popular
Rebellion has been hanged mohsin shikari
was arrested in September then sentenced
to death for injuring a security guard
here's an alleged witness speaking at
his trial
the Iranian Judiciary produced a slick
video where shikari confesses to his
so-called crime the message here is
clear dissent is punishable by death
another 21 protesters faced the death
penalty it's thought unfortunately it
was expected because we know that
Iranian authorities use the death penalt
to spread fear the reason why people are
on the streets protesting is that this
barrier of fear is broken and now they
want to use executions to restore this
barrier
the protests in Iran were triggered by
the death of a 22 year old called Masa
amini she died in police custody after
she was arrested for wearing her hijab
incorrectly
but the execution of protesters is
unlikely to quell this Rebellion people
in Iran are even more angry at the
Iranian authorities now then they were
before the execution of shikari so I we
will Ex we are expecting more protests
The clerics Who Run Iran have been
rattled by public displays of defiance
but they won't give way without a fight
John Sparks Sky News